So how does one construct a
dose response curve? Well,
you need data.
The data going essentially
empower from three sources,
animal bioassays where the toxicity is
studied in relatively large number of
animals,
human epidemiological studies,
which are often conducted
in specific subpopulation,
which can be as a regionally
specific or occupationally specific.
Finally, toxic effect can you
studied in basic cell lines,
which is much faster but has limited
relevance to toxicology here provide the
table of challenges that are
associated with each study time.
Animal studies I journey preform
at relatively high doses,
so in order to preform a meaningful
dose responsibility creation,
scientists have to extrapolate
that to a much lower dose.
This studies are expensive and take a
long time and consequently cannot perform
on a very large number of chemicals for
him off humans obviously a lot different
from rat.
Therefore,
certain physiological information is
required to extrapolate from animals to
humans or us around sorting.
Factors need to be applied.
Clinical and occupational studies
suffer from a lot of similar problems is
they're relatively expensive and
incorporate complex exposures.
Is I difficult to differentiate?
A human is exposed to many substances.
Therefore it's relatively difficult to
isolate one specific soft on psalms as
larger Rick and consequently it's very
difficult to establish a cause and effect
scenario.
Similarly,
it's difficult to study a lot of chemicals
and furthermore it's difficult to
study effect that Omarion common in the
population because one we'll have to get
a huge sample size of people
to assess row health effect.
Finally, in vitro cell bio assays have
many advantages because they are fast,
they are cheap and they're able to screen
many chemicals in a short period of
time.
However,
since their applicability to human is
even more limited and animal studies,
since bacteria watch further
evolutionary moved from humans,
it is not common to to make dose
response curves based on cell bio assays.
As I just explained some effect
of very rare in the population.
This is especially relevant
when it comes to tumors.
Some lymphomas and other blood cancers
are extremely rare and therefore hard to
detect.
Any given.
This slide basically demonstrate is that
if a disease has a prevalence in the
population of 0.01%,
which is relatively hot,
it would require thousand animals to
detect it was the probability that is high
enough is a for when
studying rare diseases,
it is very difficult to get
the right number of animals.
That's the limitation of toxicology
data is low dose extrapolation.
As you already know,
at very low doses,
it's almost impossible
to notice an effect, um,
on a reasonable number of animals.
Therefore,
you had to administer a higher dose
to see a response. Consequently,
you're not sure how the curve
behaves in a lower doses.
As you can see from the left panel is
the graph. You have some data points,
but none of them go all the
way down to zero. Therefore,
you can make approximations about that
question a we'll region in the bottom
left,
but the dose response curve down there
is not certain and that is a part we care
about. Since exposure to the
real world, I usually much lower.
It was in those in the laboratory.